[Applaudissements]
saurez-vous question moi j'ai une
anecdote avec un policier à légumes
voilà je suis allé dans un commissariat
dernièrement pour aucune quelque chose
d'un ex à tout le commissariat je dis
bien tout le commissariat m'apprit ans
elle fit non à ces questions des deux
courses
c'était terrible parce que laïc où il
était là moi j'ai trouvé ça super génial
parce que ça montre que même même dans
la police mais ils regardent les mets
juste question heureusement quand on
sait que suit l'émission parce que si
vous êtes dans la rue on dit c'est
christian des 12 coups ont pour noms
mais c'est vrai ça pue possédant sa
propre jour quand même dû au passé
christian n'émousse coutumière la
mâchoire vous jean luc est ce que vous
prête